arts education will create future
theatergoers and the love of arts in
general so this opportunity to partner
with Carnegie Mellon engages us to put a
real focus on that as we do it in both
of our own educational initiatives well
and I think our mission is really to
make sure that we have the next
generation on the stage in the ions and
behind the scenes and arts education is
critical for that because our
certification is not just about people
on the stage it's about people in the
audience that spot people behind the
scenes in addition it's about
well-rounded members of society and we
know we have plenty of evidence now you
know that arts education raises test
scores keeps kids in school and you know
makes for more well-rounded human being
and you know so we think that's
important too right so there's a real
business reason that we're interested in
it and then there's a humanity reason
that we care about it as well